[Music]
are you ready to impress your friends if
so you've come to the right place today
we'll be showing you some fun quick and
easy DIY projects that will make your
friends jaws drop but before we begin
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and give this video a big thumbs up okay
let's get started
edible water bottle this edible water
bottle is so cool and it's great for the
environment to add a gram of calcium
lactate to four cups of water and mix it
well using a spoon then take two grams
of sodium alginate
and carefully place it into the calcium
lactate mixture add another three grams
of sodium alginate to the mixture and
stir for three minutes then remove the
bottles from the calcium lactate using a
slotted spoon and transfer them to a
bowl of rinsing water to stop the
reaction and there you have it
refreshing drinking water that doesn't
require a plastic bottle growing magic
blood to make magic mud just chop some
potatoes into small pieces
then place them into a large bowl and
pour in enough hot water to cover them
completely stir the mixture for a few
minutes until the water turns red using
a strainer and a bowl separate the water
from the chunks of potatoes and allow it
to sit for 10 minutes until a white
layer appears add some fresh water to
the white layer and pour it into a
container for the lid with the lid
secured shake it up and let it sit for
10 minutes drain the water from the
mixture and you'll be left with a
substance that looks like milk after a
few days is a milk like substance will
turn to powder combine the powder with
tonic water to give it a glow effect and
you're ready to have fun with your
friends frozen silly putty to make this
frozen silly putty you'll need a bottle
of Elmer's glue 3/4 cups of cold water
1/2 teaspoon of borax 1/2 cup of hot
water blue food coloring and some silver
and blue glitter for your glue into a
bowl add the color water and glue and
stir until it's well combined add a few
drops of food coloring and stir again
then at the glitter and continue
stirring in a separate cup add the hot
water and borax and stir until it's all
combined the two mixtures into One Bowl
and your frozen silly putty is ready to
go
glow-in-the-dark playdough to make this
all-natural glow-in-the-dark Play Doh
fresh too
so the b-fifty complex vitamins until
they turn into a powder then mix the
powder with 2 cups of flour 4 teaspoons
of cream of tartar and 2/3 cup of salt
when everything is combined add 2 cups
of warm water and 2 tablespoons of
vegetable oil to the mixture put
everything together until it's smooth
add the solution to a saucepan and cook
it on medium heat until the potato forms
into a ball allow it to tool for a few
minutes take it into a dark room turn on
a backlight and watch it glow liquid
plastic get ready to completely wow your
friends because we're going to show you
how you can make this DIY liquid plastic
all on your own
slowly warm up a half cup of heavy cream
or milk when it begins to simmer clear
in a few spoonfuls of vinegar continue
adding spoonfuls of vinegar and preserve
slowly until the mixture begins to gel
let it cool for a bit and then wash the
gel mixture with water to clean it off
and you'll be left of liquid classes
that will keep you and your friends
entertained for hours for me jelly worms
these squirmy jelly worms are easy to
make and they taste delicious too you'll
need a pack raspberry jello an extra
pack of unflavored gelatin for extra
firmness 3/4 cups of whipping cream 3
cups of water blue coloring flexible
straws and 1 tall container to hold two
straws combine the gelatin in a bowl and
add the hot water let the mixture cool
until it's lukewarm then add the
whipping cream and food coloring gather
your straws and put them in the
container so they fit tightly add the
gelatin mixture inside each draw and let
it sit until they become firm then
squeeze the worms out of the straws and
proceed to devour them homemade gas
homemade GAC is made using four ounces
of Elmer's glue a quarter cup of hot
water and food coloring of your choice
and a half teaspoon of borax
pour the glue into a small container and
add half of the hot water mix together
with a spoon and then add the food
coloring dissolve the four acts with the
remaining hot water and stir then for
the borax and water into the glue
mixture and stir until it becomes solid
within minutes you'll have your very own
homemade gak water beads
making water beads is so easy and
they're edible to cook some tapioca
pearls on your stove for five minutes
using a little bit of water drain the
pearls from the water and rinse them
under cold water for a few
add a few drops of food coloring the
Brighton amount and let the coloring
absorb into the pearls for five minutes
then rinse the beads under cold water
after they dry you and your friends can
have fun playing with and eating your
edible water views slime
who doesn't love it we do a slime well
now you can make DIY slime using this
quick and simple recipe combine one cup
of water with one cup of cornstarch and
mix them together with your fingers
until it becomes confining add a few
drops of food coloring like a bright
green or blue and that's all it takes to
make DIY slime edible slime if you want
to kick things up a notch with your
slime you can make this edible version
for you and your friends to play with
and snack on at the same time just take
a quarter cup of basil seeds and add a
16 ounce box of corn starch mix the two
together with your hands and then add
food coloring and two and a half cups of
water stir well and knead the mixture
like bread dough for about five minutes
the basil seeds will begin to absorb the
water and the mixture will thicken once
the slime feels nice and smooth it's
ready to be played with and eaten will
you be making any of these DIY projects
to impress your friends react in the
comment section down below and don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up
[Music]